wenn es draußen weiß vom schnee ist
liegt der duft in der luft
jedem wurde
ehrlichkeit
sally bell in berlin tagt in der
weihnachtszeit sagt sally band wird
hallo herzlich willkommen so liest heute
habe ich ein richtig tolles rezept für
euch also wie immer aber heute richtig
cool aber richtig jetzt fällt ist
richtig toll ja diesmal habe ich eine
biskuitrolle für euch eine schokoladen
biskuitrolle mit einem schokoladen
mantel und der dokumente ist ein
bisschen besprüht mit glanz pulver und
das sieht richtig cool aus finde ich bin
stolz ich weiß nicht genau wie ich das
an schneide aber ich finde jetzt einfach
schon mal richtig cool und innen drin
habe ich einen orange gehört als in der
orangen creme sta travel card und eine
vanillecreme mit frischkäse richtig
lecker ich zeige euch jetzt zuerst
einmal die zutaten für den biscuit denn
damit geht es los für die bis mit masse
brauche ich viel eiweiß eine prise salz
4 eigelb etwas von den extrakt 120 gramm
zucker einen heißen espresso 75 gramm
mehl 50 kampfstärke und 25 gramm
kakaopulver für den bizkit nehme ich
jetzt das eiweiß und gibt es eine
saubere und fettfreie schüssel und
schlag ist gemeinsam mit dem salz steif
[Musik]
jetzt ruhig noch die hälfte des zuckers
ein damit der schnee nicht flott und
lasst uns später noch mal eine minute
weiter rühren
der einschlägige das fest den ständig
kurz zur seite
und jetzt kann ich in einer separaten
chips und das eigelb gemeinsam mit dem
model extrakt dem restlichen zucker und
im espresso für etwa vier bis fünf
minuten cremig verrühren
so sieht jetzt die eine masse aus
richtig schön voluminös und da kann ich
jetzt die trockenen zutaten zu fügen die
werden aber vorher gesehen
[Musik]
hier seht ihr auch warum ich das ziel
denn im mail oder auch in kakaopulver
und in der stärke könne aufs klümpchen
sein und die bekommt man dann nur ganz
schwer wieder raus
jetzt kann ich das ganze hier unterheben
und dann in ein schnee unter 10
[Musik]
jetzt will ich die bizkit masse hier in
meinen vorbereiteten back rahmen ein
und für streicher sie auch gut
und so kommt jetzt die bizkit platte in
den vorgeheizten backofen weil 210 grad
ober unterhitze und da braucht sie etwa
acht bis zehn minuten nach dem backen
löse ich sofort die bizkit platte mit
einem backform messer vom bug rahmen
dann ziehe ich die bizkit platte vom
backblech herunter und legt einen torten
retter drunter bevor ich jetzt ein
sauberes geschirr tuch darüber läge
betreue ich die bis chris platte mit
etwas zucker damit das geschirrtuch
nicht klebt jetzt kann ich mithilfe von
einem zweiten relatives gibt platte
wenden
die dauer bank folie abziehen und mit
hilfe des geschirrs einfach die
biskuitrolle aufrollen und so abkühlen
lassen
die biskuitrolle ist abgekühlt jetzt ist
die füllung an der reihe
ich werde eine vanillecreme machen und
darin noch ein orange körper stecken
ihr kennt wahrscheinlich alle schon das
land gehört also die richtig leckere
zitronencreme und das könnt ihr im
prinzip mit limetten machen mit orangen
aber auch mit blaubeeren und brombeeren
ist alles super lecker ich mache in
orange shirt und gibt da noch ein paar
cent blüten mit rein für das orange gurt
brauche ich eine unbehandelte orange
davon nämlich 100 milliliter saft und
auch die schale 250 gramm zucker hier
habe ich noch drei cent blüten drinnen
sind viertel teelöffel stärke und 30 g
butter und für die creme 200 gramm fisch
käse im doppel rahm stufe 400 gramm
sahne etwas puderzucker ich habe ich
jetzt etwa 50 gramm vanille extrakt und
seiner tat zuerst nehme ich jetzt die
orange die habe ich bereits abgewaschen
und da nehme ich jetzt die schale also
den orangenen passt
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich 100 milliliter
orangensaft
da gebe ich jetzt dazu dann auch den
zucker und die zehen treten wenn ihr
keine blüten findet dann könnt ihr auch
zimtpulver nehmen oder vierte zimtstange
sind blüten die riechen schon noch mal
anders als sind also ein bisschen feiner
findig und die tassen hier auch jetzt
wunderbar rein und der mich jetzt im
ganzen mit rein gegeben lasse mitkochen
und entfernen sie späteren einfach dann
noch ein bisschen stärker
jetzt kann ich die mischung bei
mittlerer hitze einfach so lange
erwärmen bisher entdeckt und dann lasse
ich sie einmal ganz kurz aufkochen
[Musik]
nach dem aufkochen kommen hier noch die
butter mit dazu und die lässt sich jetzt
in der warmen masse auf den herd habe
ich jetzt schon abgestellt und kann das
jetzt hier einfach kurz schmelzen lassen
und gleich streiche ich das noch durch
ein sieb so werden zum einen die
brötchen vielleicht vom entfernt und
natürlich auch die zins blüten während
es hier noch steht kann ich auf diese
seite schon mal die sahne steif schlagen
dafür nehme ich jetzt einfach vier
teelöffel salat und 100 gramm von der
saane werde ich gleich weglegen die
brauche ich nämlich für die deko
[Musik]
die sahne ist steif geschlagen jetzt
nehme ich den frischkäse dem gebe ich
jetzt in der separate schüssel da
nochmal zwei teelöffel salat mit dazu
dann den puderzucker und etwas vanille
extrakt
jetzt kann ich dir machen auch verrühren
und 300 gramm sahne unterheben
[Musik]
ich stelle vanillecreme jetzt noch in
den kühlschrank das orange gehört muss
jetzt auch komplett abkühlen das hätte
man am besten gleich machen morgen wenn
der pilz geht aus dem ofen kommt aber
damit freundlich tragen gedacht ist
nicht schlimm ich lasse es jetzt auch
geben beides kurz abkühlen und dann kann
ich die biskuitrolle füllen
jetzt habe ich die biskuitrolle ganz
vorsichtig auseinander gewollt da kommt
jetzt die frisch käsecreme rein und
darauf dann das orange gehört
hier am rand nehme ich immer gerne eine
tankkarte dann kann ich nämlich bis zum
rand streichen ohne das was dabei
rauskommt
[Musik]
wer möchte könnte jetzt hier noch ein
paar mandarinen spalten oder auch mal
griffen mit rein geben und ich mache es
immer so dass ich das untere drittel
oder viertel ein bisschen freilasse
damit einfach nicht raus gewählt
hier kann ich jetzt mit dem geschirrtuch
zusammen ganz vorsichtig die rolle auf
rollen und dann lasse ich sie nochmal
eingepackt haben jetzt läuft ein
bisschen raus aber das ist jetzt nicht
schlimm sieht keine nummer zwei und
jetzt kommt's thevis kontrolle noch mal
für etwa eine stunde bis 2 in den
kühlschrank damit sie schön festwirt und
der anschnitt ganz toll wird in der
zwischenzeit werde ich schon mal eine
schokoladen platte zu bereiten die
brauche ich nämlich für die deckung die
discs rolle wird es noch mit einem
schoko mandl ummantelt sozusagen
ich habe ich jetzt bereits 200 gramm
peter kurth oeri geschmolzen und zwar
mit der eben methode damit ich später
keinen grauschleier bekommen
ich habe die schokolade fein gehackt und
dann zwei drittel davon über einem
warmen aber nicht kochenden wasser bat
geschmolzen und sobald die geschmolzen
ist können das herunterziehen vom
wasserbad der festliche drittel
einrühren und ebenso lange rühren bis
sie komplett geschmolzen ist jetzt hat
die kuvertüre nämlich die perfekte
verarbeitung temperatur und jetzt gieße
ich sie hier auf ein backpapier das habe
ich bereits auf den torten retter
gesetzt buck folie würden natürlich auch
gehen aber die sind gerade alle belegt
bei mir habe ein paar plätzchen gebacken
mit samira mich eine ganz große palette
ihr könnt auch ein messer nehmen und das
ganze schön verteilen zu einer großen
platte
[Musik]
so gefällt mir die platte ganz gut und
wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr noch ein
bisschen gold oder kupfer spray nehmen
das sind lebensmittel farbpulver und so
ein bisschen was darüber geben wo sie
einen hauch nur teilweise da bekommt man
ein bisschen schimmer mit rein
die platte stelle ist so in den
kühlschrank damit sie fest werden kann
und im prinzip avancen gleich schon
geschafft festplatte für streiche ich
jetzt mit der übrigen sahne
die hat ja vorhin weg gelegt
jetzt kann ich die schoko platte brechen
jetzt habe ich handschuhe an damit ich
einfach keine fingerabdrücke
hinterlassen
jetzt könnte so brechen wir möchten und
dieser streifen lege ich jetzt auf die
biskuitrolle
[Musik]
also ich weiß es wirklich nicht so ganz
wie es anschneiden soll ich habe erst
gedacht und zacken messer aber das geht
wahrscheinlich netz macht dass das
messer 300 grad heiß und schneit durch
jetzt kennt diese brenner aber dann
schmilzt der schokoladen ich probiere
jetzt einfach okay ich habe übrigens hat
die schokolade probiert und dauernd
begast genascht die schokolade schon
lecker jetzt kann er sein natürlich die
beste messe haben wir das meistern
ordnung das messer ist okay der steige
so anschneiden immer sich auch so ein
problem wenn du deine torte hat die so
aussehen und es ist gar koling gekriegt
ja inzwischen aber mit 33 grad heißes
messer weil das tolle wetter gewesen
also wenn man es heiß macht hat man halt
dann fort also dann geht s gut durch
aber dann schmilzt sondern schmerz
halten wissen aber ich finde es ist
eigentlich arbeitet orange kirk hast du
noch nie gemacht kann es seien ja nicht
auf dem kanal privat schon öfter als
immerhin hier die strecke
sie kann täglich aus der spülmaschine
wahrscheinlich egal mio ja das passiert
ist okay durch die spülmaschine
ausgeräumt allgemeine das sparprogramm
ja okay das sparprogramm
und jetzt hat nur die schokolade mit der
creme probiert jetzt noch teig und ganz
ungewohnt weil ich eher herb des lemming
gehört erwartet ich aber meinen score
antritt kann mich auch täuschen ketsana
orangen creme der orangen creme zu
vermischen creme schmeckst du und ich
habe vor allem aber können auch noch
mango stücke reinmachen oder mandarinen
noch frucht reinbringen wie man möchte
ich zurück und wenn jemand keine dunkle
schokolade mag kann ja auch weise geholt
sagen weiße schokolade oder man kann
auch orangen stück immer schon gesagt
hat eben ehrlich aber der hersteller
jetzt so super ja nix tut nicht zu süß
wegen der neuregelung haben orangen sich
ja branchen soll ja gar sehr gut
ich finde es auch gut ich habe mich
vorher auch schon ein bisschen davon der
creme und allem genascht und falls er
das rezept auch gerne ausprobieren und
kosten möchte schaut auf meinem blog
vorbei aufs eis - blog.de
da steht noch mal alles ganz genau ich
wünsche euch viel spaß beim nachbacken
und wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal bis
dann könne aber so machen
und wie schmeckt auch noch lebt und es
schmeckt nach komisch irgendwie sein
display den morast entglitten sind
blüten sind habe ich halt geschehen taxi
alles geschieht ob body cream schavan
sind ehrlich ich finde verdreht wenn ich
mir
[Musik]
jetzt ganz müde seine augen werden ganz
schwer und die augenlider fallen zu tun
lässt seinen augen nach die augen werden
immer schwerer die wir jetzt mal wieder
auf
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ok weitergeht